this project dates back to what close to
over a decade if I'm not mistaken well
eight years ago stranger approached me
in a store and handed me an envelope
that contained newspaper clippings about
this story his name is Tom Heller and he
he's got an executive producer credit
and Capote had just come out and he said
I think you're gonna want to make a film
about this story truthfully and it's
never happened before
it just grabbed me immediately before I
finished reading the first article I
just knew that I was going to do this
and part of it has to do with the oddity
of these characters finding each other
and I think it's true of all of my films
that there are characters and worlds
where they do not belong but this one
seemed especially compelling because it
had for me an allegorical quality and
there's it's a very simple very strange
story that felt familiar and as weird as
it is a lot of the themes running
through it about wealth in class and
father issues patriotism family felt
familiar the research involved in this
must have been monumental did you
consult with the Schultz's in order to
bring this to the screen but the time
this came to me there's another writer
max Frey who who worked with Bennett for
a long time before me but Bennett had
done an enormous amount of research too
to start with he'd done hundreds of
hours of talking to wrestlers who had
who had been at Foxcatcher there was a
ton of material in terms of court
documents and
public domain articles and John du Pont
wrote several books he'd made
documentary about himself so there was a
lot there's a lot to to look at much of
which Bennett had had compiled and
worked through with Max and and he and
Max did the initial really
groundbreaking i opening to me work in
terms of formulating exactly what the
story could and should be by the time I
came on to it it felt like more of a
piece that I could work with Bennett and
figuring out how to shape that into a
movie rather than starting from scratch
from the raw materials I know Ben I
don't know if that that was your that's
exactly right
I'm Matt Bennett in a hotel in New York
and I just done I think my second film
and and he told me about this story and
and I went home gave me he gave me the
script I went home I researched the
characters a little bit in the story
again I didn't know anything about it
and I read the script and to be
completely honest I didn't know why to
make it I I think I just didn't know
enough about just storytelling and I I
was sort of just like why do you want to
make this man and I think I you know I
think God I ran back into Bennett later
and you know I guess seven years later
and I think I had done a lot of growing
and a lot of learning and why to make
movies and why to play characters and
why to tell stories and we just saw
eye-to-eye and and I'm just so thankful
that I got to go on the walk and because
I think that I don't know I understand a
little bit more about people in life
after it now Steve do you meet with
Bennett as early as Channing did or did
it come 25 years 25 years ago before he
got that that letter before this story
even took place we were talking about it
nine years before the murder Steve
called me it was about
four years ago that we we got together I
hadn't I I knew vaguely of the story
when it happened but then it evaporated
and I I didn't know anything more about
it I was sent this script I met with
Bennett over lunch and he offered me the
part it was it wasn't anything that was
on my radar I didn't I wasn't
campaigning for it so no it came as a
complete surprise to me when I first got
it were you surprised that he even came
to you in the first place yes I was
surprised um ya know and I'm very
thankful to him for that I rely I feel
like I'm I'm very much in his debt
because I don't think I would have been
on on any one shortlist to play a part
like this and my my agent submitted my
name and apparently it piqued his
interest and we met and talked about the
script so yeah I was I was surprised
happily one of our earlier early
conversation Steve said he's only ever
played characters with a mushy Center
and John du Pont seems to have a mushy
Center but he doesn't and he's dangerous
and you know being a comic Steve
naturally has a twisted dark side that
he conceals from the rest of the world
and when we met truthfully the you know
the the public persona how we know Steve
was not really very evident and he was
he was deadly serious about it and he
had read the script and he responded
strongly to the script and he had done
some research now one character that
doesn't have a mushy Center is John du
Pont mother played by Vanessa Redgrave
you appear it's true I don't know but um
do you think she has emotion senator I
listened to Bennett
no I mean that seriously sorta like that
out in the mic no I did because from
what he told me and from how he put it I
thought I'll just have to listen to you
very very carefully and then what you
know and what you're after it'll come
through me make everything about the
movie I took a very deliberate path and
needed to evolve and reveal itself along
the way it's not based on a book or as
much as it's based on reality it's
Bennett's vision that had to be realized
and with script that our great writers
and with the process that it took over
the eight years it couldn't have
happened any other way
now now Mark Ruffalo has some some
training or not some training but he
actually has some wrestling experience
I'm not mistaking training you do not
correct so how much training do you have
to undergo in order to truthfully little
train this guy movie magic is is amazing
we could train for ten years we're never
gonna be the wrestlers that these that
these men were but mark and I wrestled
for about seven months and mines till
the end of the movie till the to the end
date of the film I'd say it's about
seven months and every day I mean we
would shoot 12 hour 13 hours whatever it
was and then we would go to the gym and
we would throw each other around and so
much of what you see on screen I was
stretching each other and just being
intimate and and and I mean intimate in
a way that you can only have with
someone that is suffering with you like
and you both are terrified of the
workout that you're about to go to and
and because you know it's gonna it's
gonna hurt worse than the day before and
worse than anything you've experienced
in life but the moves are the moves
and you can learn those but what these
guys do
I mean wrestling you you don't get
famous you don't get rich you don't
there's just you don't do it for any
other reason other than it's something
that you somehow have like just had to
do in your life and that's all I can
really say about wrestling it's a
suffocating thing so you had a great
time making is amazing I'll never do it
again Steve what went into your
preparation for the role I'm guessing
not a lot of physical training not a lot
at all no no actually the the less I
learned about wrestling the better
because DuPont himself was not good at
it he didn't really have much much
experience or proficiency at it so I I
was able to learn moves fairly quick too
quickly by the way we had to he liked
not so good we figured out the best way
to do it would would be to just kind of
shoot me doing it for the first time
because I'm just that good an athlete
that's what I'm that's the point of this
this response and bill Corso who is a
makeup artist spent months working on
the character and many tests and it's
not as simple as you know matching a
guy's look but this is it's very
sophisticated designed and what it did
was I think effect Steve who can look in
the mirror and it just affected his
physicality immediately it affects
others around him you know it's a
repellent design and he people just
naturally gave him a wide berth and he
remained fairly alienated throughout the
shoot to the extent where these two guys
only got to know each other really meet
in can
the Film Festival that's and they found
that they liked each other but something
else is that you know steve carell
playing a dramatic role within three
seconds you have to buy it period and if
that doesn't work forget about it was
interesting I had a driver that would
pick me up at the hotel and bring me to
makeup and then I would spend the three
hours getting into makeup and then I'd
go out and get into the car and he drive
me to set and we talked all the way from
the hotel and he became a friend of mine
great guy
but he would not talk to me once I came
out of hair and makeup he just knew who
you were he did know who I was and he
and and there was a completely different
relationship there and I not by virtue
of anything that I was that I felt I was
doing differently so I think it I think
it helped that way I did wear cut we cut
the top off of baby bottle nipples baby
bottle nipples and shoved them up my
nose for the entire shoot and that was
excruciating so that helped with the
pain aspect but I mean the the real
thing with I think with Mark and my way
into him was really just his movement I
mean he was such a physical person and I
think that's the way he negotiated the
world and that was sort of my my path
and him I'm I met with Mark Schultz and
I bought his life rights I did not want
to venture into this thing with that guy
without some kind of an agreement
throughout the process people kept on
emerging Dave Schultz was somebody who
had a thousand best friends and I feel
like we met many of them along the way
Channing maybe you could speak to this
there was some emotional moments when
people saw you know the first time I
mean a lot like I mean I guess if any of
you have had like a hero or some
you felt like you've grown up within
your life that's sort of defined you I
mean Dave Schultz and Mark were of
legendary status in this world and if
you're in this world they are mythic
characters and and anyone that had
actual real-life moments with them could
could speak to it in a way that you just
I don't know I don't know how to really
explain it and and you know I had the
unbelievable graceful opportunity to be
able to spend a lot of time with mark
and but but Ruffalo I mean he had to
spend time with people that have are
still missing you know that part of
their life of Dave and and it was a it
was a I'm sure and incredibly
uncomfortable and yet beautiful
experience the entire way did you watch
the film with mark yeah with Mark
Schultz I will never watch it sitting
next to them but I was in the same room
with them but as he watched it yeah I'm
sure you've asked him what he thinks for
your performance yeah I think he's happy
he has a t-shirt that says Channing
Tatum played me in a movie who's playing
you